one income and most girls even if
they're making six figures aren't
racking that up right or getting
remarried that's that's the issue
and so and even in the uk i know you
guys have like bailout programs but what
if one day those are gone and poof you
have to figure it out on your own it's
like oh there's gonna women are the
highest growing um homeless population i
think
uh in my personal opinion i think a lot
of women get sold the a fairy tale
version of a relationship which is why
they're the ones to break off the
relationship most of the time i think
the fairy tale disney version hollywood
version of a relationship is what women
have been sold and so what happens is
when you get into a relationship um
you realize that it's actually work
it's not like you saw in a disney
program it's not like you saw in
hollywood it's not like the film's told
you
this is work and a lot of women are like
well this is not what i signed up for i
was told that prince charming was going
to come sweep me off my feet give me the
great life 2.5 2.4 children the white
picket fence and doves and rainbows and
all this kind of stuff and then you
realize hang on a minute we got children
we got debts to pay i mean we got a
mortgage all of this stuff and i just
think that a lot of women today have
been sold a hollywood ideal of a
relationship which is the reason why
they're breaking not just breaking off
relationships but breaking families
apart yeah because to me like love
shouldn't really matter when you have
kids
like do you do you guys agree or
disagree
at what point does a woman have
permission to leave a relationship
because it's toxic you know i i come
from a two-parent household so i don't
know if i can speak too tough on the
subject but
if the relationship at home is breaking
down it's not working
what what then um would allow the woman
to leave because children growing up in
a toxic household can't be much better
than people growing up with a single
parent that's co-parenting well mm-hmm
you know so like
but the numbers the numbers don't
support what you're saying
so the numbers it's really clear
single-parent households are worse off
than two-parent households
and to me personally i would say
cheating if it's like to the crazy right
um i think
abuse for sure um but
honestly like most things can be worked
out and if you're in a toxic
relationship like you have to look
internally because it takes two to tango
and you attract what you are thank you
so if you find yourself in toxic
relationship after toxic relationship
it's something you have to look inside
you chose the partner like i don't like
everyone's getting away from this you
are allowed to get mad you're allowed to
choose who the kid like who the father
of your kid is so after complaining that
he's a deadbeat is wasted time for my
ears because you chose him
you chose him it's like saying art like
if i was if say for example men were the
ones that have kids
would you like it if every time we had
casual sex
you had the the chance of getting
pregnant and you had no
say on whether or not
your your kid is brought into the world
whether or not your situation is all
right whether or not you're drunk and
just having casual sex whether or not
it's like you have no control then isn't
that on you to choose who you sleep with
but that's the same way for women
because you you right so if you but the
problem is women are incentivized to
make bad decisions
so women women are literally paid out so
if they if they break up a family they
get child support correct and if they if
they catch a kid by a rich enough guy
they get paid out
and so women are literally paid to make
bad decisions in the uk you can
i remember when i was young there were
girls that got pregnant they could get a
house
do you know what i mean there were girls
that got pregnant they could get money
because you get money you get a free
house you get free money every every
week
and as long as the man is not within the
household you're good so like you said
they're incentivized to make these
decisions
and say okay cool well i don't need a
man around fine i've just got me and my
child but isn't that also a system thing
as well
yeah because that happened a lot in the
works late 70s 80s early 80s that's when
it all kind of started
yeah
no it's i think it's a rotten system
because i don't understand why you're
entitled to a man's money
it's a rotten system because we we make
it like i like i i hate
i hate when women say that bro
um society
the system it's like we are that people
so if we want it to be a different way
it would be a different way but we don't
want it to be a different way because
women are comfortable with the way it is
as it is i'm telling you they're
absolutely comfortable with it they're
winning right now
yeah and it's not it's not oh sir the
world face that you've got to realize
was created to stop women from being
cast out because you know in the
victorian times
if you had a bastard charge you'd be
destitute on the street your church
would have to take women in so we we we
men created the system to make sure
women didn't go into poverty right but
what has been happening now has been
abused but was that before after
feminism before before right
so now we've set the rules
when did that happen the 1870s okay
that's around the same time no but in
the sense of this if okay
before the rules of women having the
right to be equal it wasn't like men
were like oh you're just a slave in my
room no we said there's certain things
that are for women and certain things
are for men benefits and disadvantages
but women didn't have to fight in wars
right yeah exactly they didn't have to
do hard jobs didn't have to climb
chimneys and do nothing they'd like okay
so
you're locked in the house okay your
guy's locked in a factory
he's locked in a pit like they say oh
you know it's like oh they locked us up
the guy was he didn't have minimum wage
he didn't have like he didn't have no
safety measures he was working trying to
pay for his family like way we how we
fantasize how back in the day was like
we lived there like we just came from
the revolution it's like no none of us
lived there so when you say society was
this way it's like no no that's how this
is how it is now that's how we want it
to be yeah
there's too many feminists and too many
male feminists you know i also want to
ask i want to ask um the guys here and
the one mother we have right um so
you've already got a child
and
you're you've got someone new what
obligation
does the new man have now to your child
from another
man
would you like like what like does he
take on all of the responsibility as a
father
or is there some kind of halfway
dad situation going on
does that make sense because a lot of
women
have
expect a man for instance there was a
viral video this week you know a couple
of days ago where this woman
was she had a father of her child she
had three other children and he came to
bring his child every day lunch and then
she was like oh i've got three other
kids and he's like those aren't my kids
i've got one with you i don't have an
obligation to look after your children
so i'm just like do women who already
have children think that their new man
or another man has the obligation to
look after the children that aren't his
i think it depends on if you're dating
or if you're or if you're taking things
serious i think it depends if you're
dating they don't need to see your child
you're just you know dating and doing
your thing
but if you are building with you you're
moving on and you're building with that
person you're gonna you know get engaged
get married have children and stuff it
that kind of comes with
that kind of you you kind of see how
they build their own relationship as
well i feel i feel like you do group
stuff you go out to eat you do whatever
you need to do you know and you see if
that when you're doing introducing after
six months or after a year you see if
your child how they are with that person
you need to see if they if they've got
that relationship you can't force you
can't force it
is he allowed to discipline your child
um
it depends on that situation this is the
thing because
because
yeah in my country i was in a
relationship for like 10 years right and
when i was in that relationship i was
with a woman who already had a child
we had a child together but what was
very